well welcome to new york
you know that song i'm trying to sing it
right now welcome to new york you really
don't want to hear me sing i promise
don't you don't you know
but the reason that song is running
through my head right now is because
here we are downtown new york manhattan
beautiful day tribeca and i'm welcoming
somebody to new york who always welcomed
me to stanford when the car was going
the other way when i was headed out to
hedgehog risk management which he
founded and he's the ceo of uh but this
is keith mccullough's first trip back to
new york city and
to mark the occasion he's allowing us to
switch roles
so he's typically trying to get me to
drop an f-bomb
interviewing me
and it's been via zoom these last few
years uh but now i'm not going to get
and drop any f-bombs because this is a
rated g show um but we are going to
switch roles and we're going to find out
a little bit more about who keith is so
welcome welcome thanks for having me
you're not from new york at all no
you've joked with me for years about
being canadian but i've never actually
asked the very simple question because
canada is kind of a large place
where are you from in canada
a town called thunder bay ontario which
we get in a car from you know the new
york of canada toronto you go 20 hours
north you'll get there so
it's a it's a long haul it's a i'm a
long way from new york today
i thought you were going to say montreal
or vancouver or toronto or something
generic
well i guess there's not much to do
there than play hockey yeah that's
that's the big part of the big big part
of the life up there it's right at the
head of lake superior which is you know
beautiful lake it's one of the largest
lakes in the world and um
i grew up there with you know my
my whole family still lives there or in
other parts of canada so i'm the one
that moved to the usa first so what's
the name of the town again thunder bay
ontario thunder bay and here i'm
googling it after we finish with this
but so my real question is when at what
age did you start playing hockey uh
as soon as i could so probably three
three four something like that three
four five years old we have something in
common when i was four years old in
connecticut it was the first and last
time i was ever on ice skates on but you
would presumably be
ice skating on actual water
i mean it's all we did i mean everyone
kind of had their own either hybrid
backyard rink or then you had the
neighborhood outdoor rink and then you
had the nine indoor rinks that i think
that i think it's still nine in thunder
bay so it's really breeding grounds for
for nhl players i didn't make it to the
nhl but there's plenty of uh plenty of
hockey talent that's developed fender
bay
wow
okay i'm really googling it um so
your life before connecticut let's
what happened in that chapter of your
life kind of after high school but
before yale well i went to four
different high schools public high
schools four yeah yeah which and they
weren't you know new england prep
schools let's put let's just you know be
clear were you a bad student
i was a bad boy sometimes it may
surprise you
the uh shocked
hold on time out oh my gosh huge
surprise
have you seen yourself on twitter okay
keep going yeah
the you know i left when i was 16 to
play hockey so the in thunder bay like
my dad said to me said look it's time
for
big fish in a small pond to go to the
bigger pond and i didn't actually quite
like the idea initially but when i was
16 i left i haven't been home really you
know since other than for christmas and
now in the summertime i'll go back but
um what happened was that i'd get traded
you know and it wasn't always because i
was bad or that you know anything like
that but it was i one at one point when
i was 17 i tore my knee up so that team
traded me to another town and i had to
go to their high school and then when
you're done the hockey season you have
to go back to thunder bay and find the
classes that are aligned with the
classes that you had so my track my high
school transcript is a bit of a band-aid
you know and
wow i did okay i still ended up i think
i had
i think i had the lowest sat score at
yale for my class so that was kind of
the bridge but it was it was literally i
was living away from home trying to live
out my dream playing hockey
well that's i mean
my my boys attend culver military
academy i mean they recruit hockey
players
um good ones
yeah it's yeah it's a good high they
don't they don't play hockey think
heavens those hockey boys are
they're bad boys some of them um
in any event
so did yale recruit you to play yeah
yeah okay so that's that's how you ended
yale yeah so i mean i didn't back then i
really didn't know the difference
between
no offense to rpi or
you know boston university or anything
like that excellent hockey teams but
yale was one of the teams that was
interested so you do your five visits to
the schools that are
interested in having you wear their
jersey and then then then they figure
out if your grades are good enough so
that's where i started you know the
whole yale thing started to be a little
bit more problematic and but somehow i
got it done and i'm you know it was uh
when i ended up in new hampshire
connecticut from thunder bay ontario i
thought that was the industrial mecca of
the world i mean it was um
it's it's it's pretty industrial i mean
it's pretty rough
if you want to use that i mean it's not
like bridgeport but still yeah i mean in
thunder bay we grew up very modestly i
don't like to think of people being part
of a class i think that's you know
that's i'm not going to use a bad word
on your uh
chair program but i mean i you know my
dad my dad was a firefighter my mom uh
was a teacher and
you know i grew up with one of three
kids yes my sister
was younger than me and so is my brother
um and i would never guess that you were
first born either
yeah these uh you know these gen x
problems
here
we'll get into the demographic
discussion
we have a lot of issues gen x people
particularly those that have left home
i'm aware i actually um my family is
from east haven uh connecticut really so
yeah so i i grew up going to pepe's
pizza
when i would come visit connecticut so
in the summer times it was a lot of fun
i mean
but yale is its own microcosm truly
within that city yeah i mean right
before i got there one of uh a young
hockey player got stabbed at like a pop
eyes i was like oh okay this is a little
man we have some of that in thunder bay
yeah a little different kind of fights
and stuff like that i was like wow i
feel at home this is good this is
yeah um so
championship
at yale yeah you mean hockey yeah you
were the captain yeah i mean one of the
years i was when i was a senior um
you know they only have one so that was
my senior year and we won an ivy league
championship which is not as good as a
what we call an ecac championship that's
what we won as a junior that was at the
time the best yell hockey team in a long
history of yale team so we're super
proud of that
big time underdogs uh we were definitely
not supposed to achieve that which is uh
yeah to me that was like a big that was
a big deal oh heck yeah it was i mean
well i mean it was a culmination of a
journey yeah
um
but
all due difference since we both love
central banker so much and phd's in
economics we have that in common you
studied why did you choose to use to
study economics of all things i i'm
being like being on a bus all the time
hockey bus i mean that's where i started
you know voraciously reading if you will
like we didn't have techs we didn't have
anything and these are like long bus
rides oh yeah and and that was really
the subject matter that that that i was
most interested in i was always very
interested
um in math um so that was my principal
orientation i should say my mom is
french canadian as a first language so i
went to school up until the fifth grade
i went to french only school okay so i
learned how to do math in french and and
i learned how to do pretty much
everything in french so math was always
the most accessible thing because i
didn't have to
you know change all the words and um
so that makes sense so i'd read a lot
like a lot of finance you know
autobiographies biographies anything
that had to do with history and and math
and the evolution of it all that was my
thing so
when you know it's it's a ba at yale and
you get to you know elect your major um
as you're kind of going through it and
since the only class i was going to get
an a in freshman year at yale was in
french because i spoke
um
so you didn't take an andrew got it yeah
i did not enroll in the electrical
engineering department of yale
i was not on the track to be the biology
major the physics major et cetera so
that's that that's a good economics
department um
who
who are your mentors
and who and i'm not just talking about
yale in your time there but
in your career
who who do you look at and say gee that
person inspired me
of my parents for sure i mean i was so
fortunate that's lovely you know my
parents my my aunts and uncles i mean i
grew up in a family of teachers overall
at some
stage of their career you know all my
aunts were actually my mom and her two
sisters these three uh french girls were
all the principal you know of the of the
french school so i mean i was
yeah those were my those were my and my
coaches you know i was sure i i i didn't
until i got traded i didn't end up with
some bozo coach that was just like
they're a lot of bad coaches uh hockey
coaches but um so i had some great
coaches uh and that's kind of all i knew
up until
going to you know then all of a sudden i
get the u.s olympic coaches my coach tim
taylor who you know god rest his soul
he's the best he was
beyond people that i'd known my whole
life he was easily the most important um
influence on my life uh in any way shape
or form that's
wow but i'm pleased you said your
parents because that's just
that's so amazing since we're not
talking about our eight kids yet yet
and that's i'm looking at the camera now
that's not our eight kids it's eight
kids between keith and i combined
um
so you started off with an econ major as
an equity research analyst yep what was
that transition like what was this here
in new york yeah the first the first
transition i had to make was accepting
that i was not going to play in the nhl
so you know
the peak of my hockey career was you
know were those championship teams and
really actually understanding how to be
a great teammate more so than being an
nhl star yeah so i got
you know told that i'm not good enough
to play in the nhl
and then i also was is 1999.
you know the best time to have us a c on
your yale jersey within with a resume
that said hey look you know i'm hireable
yeah yeah um so that's you know i i it
was it was really humbling i mean the
amount of money that they were offering
at that point was as much as anyone my
dad you know firefighters had ever made
sure so i was like wow this is better
than playing in the minors
[Laughter]
so i i ended up taking uh an offer from
credit suisse and then they put us on
the road oh full circle
because that's where i ended my career
it was credits
mainly because they dlj got bought out
by i would have never chosen to work at
credit suisse but anyways i i digress so
proud interesting co so what what was
your first industry that you covered uh
well i just i was a general so i covered
everything like anything that was on the
desk and back then it was there were
ipos like crazy so i was like one of the
people on the desk that would be tearing
through reds as they call them oh yeah
you know they weren't electronic you had
to actually read the physical and then
you'd call you know we're we're covering
hedge funds so that's how i became a buy
set analyst i basically i didn't spend a
lot
a long time on the
cell cider at credit suisse it was just
just over a year and then one of our one
of our clients at a major head hedge
fund hired me to be an analyst gotcha
from there
so how long were you
kind of
a hedge fund guy
all the way up until i started hedgehog
you know so uh
from 2000
i believe from 2000 and
yeah 2000 just making sure i get all the
years right from 2000 uh until
and
late 2007 which was when carlisle fired
me as a hedge fund manager so that's
that's well on this day by the way
november the 2nd of 2007 that's when
carlisle bluewave fired me so happy
anniversary
i was going to write about it this
morning because i usually do i'm like
i just like saying that i got fired
because it's the first time that i
unequivocally was told get the hell out
of here you know i was never told that
on a hockey team and i never told that
on like
in any family meal
was it because you were aware of
something that they weren't well i was
short the market and that was not
working up until
well from november 2nd
of 07 that ended up being the worst
first down month for the s p 500 men oh
i recall yeah so i started hedge
actually with that big bear market call
um which is why some people think of me
as a perma-bear but not anymore maybe
right right right yeah
what an interesting time though i mean
you saw the dot-com
you saw everything you saw it all blow
up yeah i mean it it's just i i mean i
think on wall street you're largely a
function of the cycle time you spend so
whenever you showed up on the desk
whatever job you had that's largely
going to impact
you know lacey hunt isn't lacy hunt and
you know you take any person who
capitalized on the the deflation the
long-standing deflation and it's usually
where they start you know um and
yeah i was lucky i went through two
massive bubbles and
ended up on the right side of both and
yep um
yeah yeah so so it's it's it's always
interesting to hear when people kind of
get onto wall street because it's i mean
pivotal me david rosenberg will tell you
all day long you know october 19th 1987
that was his first day at work i'm like
wow that was a doozy yeah and obviously
it left its imprint um
and he's somebody else who became
bullish later on in his career and was
disregarded people literally
ignoring the fact that you're not
perma anything that you're
that you're you're an analyst and that
you're you know you're trying to figure
out where risk lies so i'm i'm curious
this diary of a hedge fund manager
when did you find time to stop and write
a book because it took me two and a half
years well i thank god i had rich blake
who's the you know he wrote it with me
he basically wrote it like this should
be clear i mean if you if you're to read
that book at that time you'd say wow
keith's really gotten better at writing
i mean
um
my my first my fr i tell the story often
for an apologies for people who've heard
it before but my first english lit paper
at yale was deemed ungradable
like and it was
not c minus ungradable tim taylor my my
mentor gets this call like
who's this guy
who'd you let in to this point
which is kind of nuts that i write a 6
to 800 word essay every day
so it goes to show you can start from a
very low place
and become a professional writer you
know
but those
you know those
the diary of a hedge fund manager was i
wanted to tell the story of how i ended
up being where i was
you know and a lot of again it's all
about your cycle time like my first job
action wall street was as an intern for
a guy by the name of um tiger williams
and he was the head trader from tiger
management who's split off and to a
degree i did what he did but i did it
with analytics he did it for trading so
he was the outsourced trader for all the
tiger cubs that were spinning off i was
gonna say this is i mean
julian robertson himself used to wander
around dlj yeah so i mean when when the
tiger cubs were born that was like a big
deal yeah so there's and they're all
sorts of these guys so i was like and i
was just the guy on the desk taking
trade tickets like black tickets or buys
i've learned that
i knew three colors black tickets were
buys red tickets were shorts and what
color the mail was because i had to open
all the mail and that was my job and but
what i learned from that period until i
got my first job at credit suisse when i
was on the buy side
was a like they're they're guys that
crushed it like ken uh
john griffin who ran blue ridge capital
and there are guys like kenny london who
ran redcoat capital who eviscerated
himself and went away so i'm like oh
that's how the game goes it's a lot like
hockey if you blow up you aren't in the
game so that's where i really you know
diary of a hedge fund manager to a
degree tells
my story within the lens of my traverse
but also why
i got fired in 2007 and why i was
starting this crazy idea called hegei
right so
so um
you set out to build the espn of finance
and let me tell you when you're when
you're physically inside of hedgehog
inside of your
offices it's kind of got that vibe yeah
but what
is that something that was that a
headline writer or was that your goal
what was i i struggle i still struggle
you know like trying to explain what the
hell hedge i is um
to a larger audience of people you know
so back then i was like well just think
and i mean people the people like with
the capital t and capital p because
that's really
always been my goals to democratize like
world-class research for the people so
it shouldn't just be hidden inside of a
world-class hedge fund where you just
you know you get paid your 2 and 20
nobody else gets to see that yeah this
kind of goes back to
not that yes but my mom asked me you
know when i was
doing well in the hedge fund business
she's like i still don't understand what
you do
and we're
in front of our the lake the lake house
in thunder bay ontario and i'm like
you know i tried to explain it to her
for the up team time and she's like she
wasn't and and then she just said well
how do you change the world that way
and i was like i i mean i probably had
six beers at the point that i was you
know just you know just as like a
saturday yeah and i just started crying
i was like i didn't know
i didn't
i i said i can't
like you know you know and here's the
house that we built but you know this is
the profession that i chose and
this house we're standing in front of
his beautiful lake house and my dad and
my brother and i built more so my dad my
brother a lot a lot more so for anybody
who knows me um
um yeah it's like
so at that point i real there's like no
amount of money that you can make in
this business that i think that i could
answer this question properly so when i
went through this whole hedgehog you
know writing of the book and i tried to
tell that story too there's more to this
than just
you know um
than than what everyone
living in new york city or as my former
self would think and it's not not to poo
poo what everybody does in new york city
no not at all it's sure it was you know
it was
it was my path and my journey so when i
really thought that through
like i was like okay
over the course of the years that you
know well we're going to try to be the
espn of fans you know like try to
try to tell you the blow by blow of the
score like what's actually happening in
the market as opposed to what people say
should could or would happen you know so
so that was one way to do it i think if
i were to say it a different way today
it's more like the hbo finance which we
have you on you know oh sure we have
swearing um there's no swearing on espn
and uh
but
there isn't
there's a dead laptop i love it
i've learned a lot from that too because
sometimes as you know i could be a
little moody but uh
you know um ted i i thoroughly enjoyed
ted lassa so you so just just to explain
you have investing summits
yep and so what are they in to whom are
they available so they're available
those that's a great example of
democratizing access you know to the
people i mean they're available to
anybody who clicks on it and the
investing summit is to get you know the
sharpest minds in the world like
yourself and anyone um
anyone who's timely and topical i think
that that's a big thing as opposed to
just inviting the same old b-roll of
sure who you know was good and a lot of
people get bad at this you know they may
have made a big call and
never get another one right so we're
trying to that the investing summit is
basically set up to okay what is timely
and topical good example this most
recent year has been inflation
um and just get the right people to have
a real conversation with no commercials
like this
um
so okay so i have to ask
because
you look at the world through a very
structured
prison
what's a quad
it's very
it is very structured it is a uh i live
it's a quad i live a very structured
life you know it's the same time of the
alarm clock it's the same organizational
set of tweets it's the same process the
same bean counting every day so the quad
the quad is basically a two by two model
so growth and inflation
and
it's measured and mapped in rate of
change terms on a year over year basis
so
if growth is accelerating it's either
quad one or quad two uh if growth is
decelerating it's either quad three or
quad four
and then you add the inflation component
if you have growth and inflation
accelerating that's quad two the
opposite of that is quad four which is
growth and inflation decelerating or
deflation so each quad like when you
when you just look at it there's four
economic scenarios
goldilocks is quad one quad two is rip
roaring fun like we have right now
everything goes up high shortage of
stocks all the better uh today it was
avis which i had a lot of fun with uh i
think all of a sudden it's halted and
it's like oh we're having a game stop
so that only happens in quad two
interest rates only go up in quad two um
so and stagflation is quad three
and deflation is quad four
so what we what we did was we back
tested these economic conditions against
all asset classes 50 different countries
all asset classes fixed income equity
commodities obviously and
you know some things work in certain
quads and some things don't
so i am very i very much play in inside
of my box like that that four quadrant
box or the quads as we invented it to be
is the most important
uh thing that we do i've built a big
signaling process ahead of that because
it front runs the quads as the market
would it front runs the next economic
condition so let's let's have a real
world example um let's let's just say
commodities because commodities was one
of the hottest calls
coming into um really 2019 2020 because
it had it was so far disconnected from
the stock market there are all these
charts running around that there's this
massive dislocation so you've got to be
where commodities are where where would
commodities fall in the quad well
commodities are along in quads two or
three those are the two quads that have
inflation
accelerating so our model went bullish
it was one of the bigger
calls knock on wood that we've had right
in a while which is in june of 2020 that
was the big reveal there's
mathematically it's mathematically
impossible not to have reflation to
start and then inflation
after that so reflation is just the rate
of change of deflation
negative oil price is going to go
positive to use a very basic example in
commodities or plenty of commodities
that have been in structural decline or
deflation for a long long time you know
i didn't have to know about all the
supply gaps and bottlenecks that we were
going to have at this stage of inflation
i just had to do my job and
you know god willing two feet on the
floor every day and bean count what
commodities are doing every day which
drives inflation higher um so now
obviously we have rip roaring inflation
a year and a half later and it's been
it's a good example of writing a macro
trend you know writing a macro trend in
its purest form
where you're not
who makes calls on commodities i don't
know and i don't really care i mean what
we know on wall street is that people
are siloed equity department fixed
income people you know bond kings queens
whatever um
and commodities was kind of shot for
debt so that was a that was a great
example of
any time we're in quad two or three you
buy commodities what what commodities
it's generally based on on our signaling
process
which can go through that if you want
yeah because we're having a little bit
of a disconnect right now actually since
you bring it up we're having a little
bit of a disconnect between the x energy
complex and energy
i mean obviously you know on a
fundamental level what's happening in
china is is playing into what's
happening in the x energy sector and
what's playing
out in you know with winter is coming in
europe and in china that that's both
that both being affected by you know
russia and
how nice it's
playing or not playing in the sandbox
how you know it's its capacity to
to deliver at actual natural gas because
every part of the supply chain right now
is all screwed up how nitty-gritty does
something like commodities within the
quad play out i mean right now we've got
energy going in one direction and x
energy going in another direction
obviously the china slowdown on the x
energy side is playing into that to an
extent but at the same time at the other
end of the spectrum winter is coming and
we've seen some radical moves and
end turnarounds uh in anything in the
energy complex which russia clearly you
know
russia clearly plays a hand in that and
its own capacity to
to deliver but does it get that
specific yeah we get we measure map
every single commodity that trades from
tin to cotton to copper i mean
china like and we also have a quad for
china like china's in quad deep quad 3
stagflation which they have
you know the bad kind of inflation and
yeah they're nominal or they're they
have a stagflationary ship show yeah i
just used a bad word on my own show very
bad
and imagine this like i've we've had
that view since since the beginning of
the year china was going to have a
show quad 3 stagflation if you backtest
chinese equities against any other quad
the worst quad for the stock market to
be in this quad 3. so that makes a lot
of sense it's actually a very damning
quad for most em because these countries
right um obviously can find faster
levels of inflation than than most
because their currency they're
chinese not so much because they don't
allow their currency to be devalued but
if you look at argentina the go-to moves
just devalue the currency then you get
more inflation get more inflation but um
you know the jedi mind trick this year
for us was to stay long commodities and
be bearish on china because a standard
stock and shelf kind of linear econ as
i'd affectionately call them would say
oh you're bearish on chinese demand
therefore you should be bearish on on
commodity commodities and that's just
not the way that we do it yeah so again
we measure and map every single
commodity
on a price volume volatility basis and
that gives us our signal and you know
you've seen you've you have seen some
some blow ups in different commodity
prices but then you've seen them resurge
again i mean corn is the most obvious to
have
you know corrected and looked like it
was going to break down now it's
breaking out again lumber did the same
thing um but you have seen a broadening
of the base of inflation
as these supply chain bottlenecks have
come to be which has only
amplified our you know inflation call
but globally we also have global
inflation's been a big theme so
the question just is are you uh are you
south korea uh china which are in quad
three stagflation or are you
uh parts of europe and um canada for
that matter or the usa that's in quad 2
which is the good kind of inflation for
now it's not going to last but for now
it's not going to last so that that
brings us to the fed
my favorite subject in the whole world
federal reserve
take a step back for a minute and and
maybe
share your reflections because
you're right timing can be everything so
you know there are a lot of hedge funds
that are not in business not because the
hedge fund managers themselves weren't
good but just because you know the
invisible hand of the
of the fed is now very visible and it's
put them all out of business quite a few
of them out of this yes um but how has
the role the intrusiveness the role that
the fed plays
how has that evolved
your
view of managing risk
big time i mean
let's just start with a very basic fact
if you if you aren't constantly evolving
your process you will not be a
successful hedge fund manager across
economic cycles
every cycle there's a different way to
do it and what happens in the hedge fund
business is that people are either
resting on their laurels of their former
self or they're just too dogmatic or too
too damn smart too intelligent to change
what they do
so i've had to change that and usually
it takes me to make a big mistake so
2011 was the colossal mistake that i
didn't believe that ben bernanke
twisting the curve could change the
economic outcome of europe and or the
u.s stock market
so i went from both bearish and 08 to
bullish in april of 009 to bearish in
2010 i'm feeling like oh man i've nailed
three massive macro calls here
and then i just rode that sucker right
into the the lows
and stayed with it and voila i guess he
called it innovation but
to me
like that was a moment where okay
which and if i go back and look at my
former self a lot of the criticism i
give wall street or you know what a
twitterratty these days is that you keep
talking about what should happen in the
world as opposed to what is happening
right and that's what so that's at that
point we you know i talked about it the
quads are growth and inflation model but
then we started calling it our growth
inflation policy model
so to front run their
proactively predictable behavior
we just need to know these two
conditions so then i just said okay i
disagree with all of it but i'm not
going to make money because of that
you know so
you know just trying to proactively
predict human behavior in their cases
relative i actually think relatively
easy any time you get a quad 4 economic
condition they go double
yeah you can say that they shouldn't go
dovish they shouldn't do this they
shouldn't do that which i agree with
yeah but i'll still
go with the
quad framework on what asset allocation
decisions i'll make irrespective of what
i think in principle of all this money
printing and and my moral hazard
well so but there is something a little
bit different going on than what we've
had to deal with and that's real
inflation yep
and
you know people are you know people have
been asking me you know is the fed about
to make a policier
if they do this or is the fed about to
make a policy error if they do that and
i'm like yes and yes
so i mean the fed's
pretty boxed in right now yeah i mean
depends on how boxed in
they want to be relatively speaking to
how boxed in
they actually are
they could just you know they could just
unilaterally state that inflation
remains transitory when
at this stage it's it's trending to new
cycle highs
and the bond market raises rates for
them anyway which is exactly what's been
happening the two-year yield has doubled
which only happens in quad 2. the bond
market in 2013 and 2017 this year um has
raised interest rates for the fed and
when ironically enough in 2018 and at
the end of q3 when the fed when powell
made his first policy mistake the
economy had peaked and he was tightening
into a slowdown so that to me is like
the number one risk
anytime i see the timing on the fed's
map and this
i don't i mean you you'll have an
opinion on it as well but if i just look
at my quad map
we're going to hit quad 4 and q2 of
2022.
that's very bad so if you raise interest
rates in march of 2022 you will be
tightening like south korea did into a
quad 4 slowdown and that's when you talk
about shows 100 of the time that
the fed does that the market collapses
then they have to come up with the next
idea
which in this case should be mmt right
ahead of the midterms so that's
currently how i'm thinking about what if
they do make a policy mistake they'll
try to reconcile with the next
innovation i guess they'll call mmt
uh yeah that would that would require a
massive change of leadership at the fed
but it's clear that we've got a lot of
changes going on in in the personnel
department
human resources at the fed is really
busy these days
we're throwing people out the door yeah
um
and i think the administration has
it's there's probably with good reason
that they said that they would make the
announcement on labor day and here we
are in november going hello is anybody
home well they had some trading issues
with fed members i guess oh i mean the
scandals and everything this is this is
actually um
and this is my point to to your modeling
i would argue right now that the fed is
an uncharted territory for the fed
because
of
just kind of the confluence of events
that have
gone that have transpired in a very
short period of time in an organization
where everything's drawn out
so
i'm i'm just
i'm i'm wondering how this could how a
double policy or potentially
could could affect you know how how risk
is viewed in a market that is
i mean i don't know where are stocks
right now
all-time high 60th all-time closing high
of the s p 500 yesterday 37th for the
nasdaq yeah
it's been great
yeah that i think this is what i mean my
former self absolutely would have been
run over by this i mean i would have
shorted the market the whole way up i
would have kept saying okay my 10 12
correction is going to happen at a later
date and then i'd have no credibility
right um
but
again if you understand the dynamics of
what's happening reopening
re-acceleration the timing of that delta
variant rolling over reopening me coming
to new york it's just one of the many
qualitative things you can say but
um
we have predictive tracking algos that
track the entire economy across
different mobility measures measurements
we listen all the company conference
calls i have 80 analysts so the we see
what you know
u.s steel said about ford and the auto
manufacturers we're seeing an unlocking
of this this supply glut we're starting
to see them reorder oh yeah so so that
the power of that at this stage going
into year end is as powerful as powerful
gets so i've been
looking if anything the melt up that
we've been looking for in the stock
market is going to create i think it's
going to create this wiley coyote moment
of oh my god and now we're going to go
down from up here
that's what i think next year is going
to look like
and with the fed being
completely
in the wrong spot at the wrong time on
this oh because if my inflation numbers
are right i mean i have i have headline
cpi running north of six percent
the dallas fed paper on on oer on rent
is running seven eight nine percent um
and if i just plug that in my model i'm
being conservative on where inflation's
going to be
so
they're like i said they either outright
ignore that and don't tighten
or they do
and
they're in a tough spot
i mean you're talking about the full on
and that's why i think that there might
be an actual
secular move within fed policy but by
law they're not allowed to ignore their
inflation mandate i mean it's
it's it's what they have
oh but they have they completely have
they've abandoned it we're beyond
average
blah blah blah it's just i have 118
slides in our current macro themes deck
that shows there are at least a dozen
federal reserve
data series which include fed
expectations
new york fed expectations on u.s rents
uh any now cash that they've the
cleveland fed even is okay let's even
use the cleveland fed nowcast for cpi
which just doubled and it's actually
north of five percent so on their own
metrics and what powell did at the
jackson hole meeting
was
on some level uh i'd say it was a lie
and in fact
it was a lie
to anchor on what used car prices did in
the prior month as his outlook for
transitory inflation
when new car prices are double the
impact on the cpi anyway and we're
ripping it doesn't like and they're
buying 40 billion a month of
mortgage-backed securities in the
housing market is just
ballistic yeah
so they should have raised rates already
and and and in the history at least
until it changes
until until i screw up the next time i
go with if the economy's in quad 2 and
interest rates are going up and the
fed's raising rates it's fine
it's just when you raise rates into a
slowdown so they had their chance they
didn't do it
and now they're
they're probably in
a spot they don't want to be
uh no and you know
tradition dictates that the fed doesn't
really do anything when there's
a little bit of of a political meltdown
in the country which i mean
you know the ticks you know the clock is
ticking on the december the third
next deadline for the debt ceiling and i
mean fiscal policy
i mean did that
how did that manifest in your model
because 42.3 percent of gdp injected
directly into the veins of americans in
an 18-month period that
how did that show up quad two
quad two's the party inflation and the
party no it's it's
quad 2 is is a rate of change
acceleration in consumption growth i
mean q2 of 2021 was 12.2 percent
year-over-year gdp growth i mean the
prior cycle high was 3.3
so that's where and and then and then we
had the delta variant which peaked in
august q3 slowed
it was going to slow anyway because that
was the peak against the prior base
effect but
and now it's re-accelerating again
because there's 4 trillion incrementally
in u.s bank your bank accounts right now
including money market deposit
so that's gonna it's gonna i still think
it's gonna be the biggest thanksgiving
in american history biggest christmas
for us irish people um
anywhere you go you can see it but most
importantly even if i didn't see it i
see it in our
in our predictive tracking algos and i
see it in our quad model
can can the quad give off false signals
well the signals don't give off false
signals they're that's what they are
right but the the the the
forward-looking quads can often be wrong
or the numbers can change in other words
like my forward outlook for for a quad 4
which is an economics a real economic
slowdown
which which could be fairly dramatic
against these types of numbers in q2 of
next year well it's all about the
midterms if that if that doesn't end up
being quad four
it's going to be a quad one i don't know
how you get there but that's the whole
point about market signals is they're
very good at sniffing out where that
quad outlook is going to be wrong that's
why i use the signals because i'm not
willing to
when i'm wrong what's happening when i'm
wrong on the market what's what's
happening is that my signals are
changing therefore it's telling me the
quad's going to change that's why
when i'm wrong it's very obvious when
i'm wrong i don't stay wrong
a lot of people do right they're just
willing to say no this is my call
i'm going to stay with it well
unfortunately for me and my family we
don't that's not how we make money
so uh talk to me a little bit about
volatility because
it's
i mean
what i follow the most closely is the
move index because the move always is
going to flash
eventually credit risk before and right
now the move is going in an opposite
direction of the vix index so so
treasury volatility is going through the
roof and equity volatility is still
as it would be apropos in quad 2
is kind of on the floor still and not
reacting at all well the move the move
can move in a good way or a bad way the
move always moves when there's a change
in growth and inflation expectations or
the short end of the curve because the
move is coagulated closer to the short
end than the long end but so our view
has been yeah we're short two-year
treasures we're showing 10-year
treasures we're sure third year
treasuries because
anytime you get a breakout in the
volatility of an asset class people get
out of that asset but
and that's what you should do if you're
in quad 2 you should be getting out of
treasuries now if the relationship was
and it's a very basic
similar set like i've tried to build
everything in terms of like fractal
patterns so you have a similar set being
like use very basic one the move against
high yield to oas spread
now high yield oas spread looks a lot
more like the vix so unless you get
the move moving up alongside the vix and
or high yield spreads
you're in quad too
you know quad 2 is a very volatile
situation for people that are not
positioned properly there was a huge
positioning problem a couple weeks ago
where you could see a lot of
who who knows who they were or what you
know what they had to do but you could
see it all crowding into i got to sell
these
yeah one year notes two year notes five
your notes and what was what was the
catalyst at the time well i mean it was
it was the debt ceiling kerfuffle and
and and it was these these inflation
numbers just keep coming in
so um one like
i'm
i'm a lot of things i got a lot of
issues but i have never missed calling a
quad 4 market meltdown you know we
invented the model so that's pretty easy
to say but
quad 4 conditions are when you have the
move moving
the mother of all risks would be the
move moving up the vix breaking out and
high yield spreads widening above like
350 over on high yield ois and every
time i've seen that i just okay
oh flip the switch yeah
so you're not a u.s voter
no
um i'm a green card holder yeah well yes
with our american kids a beautiful
american wife
but
what do you make of what's going on in
washington dc right now i mean i have
never
in my career at least
i gave an entire speech in new orleans
recently that said
economics is politics politics is
economics you can't un
you can't disentangle the two mm-hmm
so i mean
again
what what are your i'm not i'm not
asking what your political affiliations
are i'm just wondering how you think
politics itself right now
is it i mean because
the fiscal spending that they're even
contemplating is what's spread out over
a 10-year period
so it's not not quite the same as giving
you know handing out 1400 checks like
candy
to americans direct deposited
yeah i mean
this is unsustainable i mean i i uh
politically i'm i'm neither republican
or a democrat i'm canadian right um so
and i think most people always like that
line by the way no i'm not i'm but you
know it's an interesting like today's
election day and my kids are home from
school and some of them are old enough
to understand um
and i
yeah my son says so who who would you
vote for i said nobody
none of these people are in my vote like
i i think over at least over
time in this country
um i've seen i mean both political
parties have gravitated towards the same
economic and monetary policy yes they
have so i'm not you know like
to me it's it's disgusting it's going to
end very badly and my job is to time
when um but under no certain terms am i
like sitting here like hey guys this is
great i just made you know
ava's rental car just you know went
limit up halted today and
i made a pile on it you guys are awesome
like that's
i did but it's not i don't feel like
that that was a it's a good policy
that's driving some of these things you
know some of these these issues that we
have in this country and i guess the
only other
there could be a lot of points but i
think that the the real problem
politically is that the tapestry of
leadership like where's the moral code
where's the objectivity where's like
like when i said my mentor is the former
you know god rest his soul former u.s
olympic hockey coach
where's that guy in america like yeah
you know
running a political party or being on
the front lines
i haven't seen it in such a long time
that it's almost like i i live in canada
where i live in europe
yeah i mean it's it is definitely
conspicuous
in its absence and i think that makes it
difficult for american children
especially because you want to be able
to look up to and idolize
people in congress i mean becoming a
senator that should be a lifetime
accomplishment it shouldn't be licensed
to for for insider trading i mean it's
just laughable to me that they're
criticizing what appears to have been a
major insider trader or trader trading
scandal at the federal reserve and it's
the congress that's doing the
criticizing when they're the most
notorious insider selling sales people
in the world i mean they've made more
money off of their
front running their own policies than
any entity on planet earth yeah it's
great i mean you know our my colleague
neil howe who you know
he wrote the fourth turning we're in the
fourth term
and neil's about um he's writing his
next book which he's been spending he's
he's like
he keeps telling me it's like i'm
climbing a mountain i'm climbing them
out and like
dude it's all about the other side i
mean yeah the the framework that he
gives is to me that's the most
accessible framework because it's time
and space it's demographics it's
generations
the baby boom generation and or anyone
older than them have signed off on this
and the only way to make it different is
to get the next generation to take it
over after they completely mess it up
that's that's that's consistent across
all of human history
so i think we're watching that
yeah i mean we're watching the average
age of a u.s senator just continue to
creep higher and higher and higher and
higher i'm like
i mean go away i mean make room for
another generation of leaders clearly
the country needs
better leaders um
so
talk talk a little bit about because we
we both deal with it
talk a little bit about haters
because i think haters in my life
just i'm talking about twitter i mean it
just um
there's all this
they hide behind it on
anonymity
so that you don't know actually who they
are and they just spew and spew and spew
and it's not getting any better
no no it's um
i i mean who raised these people that
that's what i as a mother i want to know
who raised these people
well to hate is not i mean it's it's not
an uncommon thing unfortunately i mean
so
i
perversely i love which i'm sure you can
tell i love to be hated i love to be
hated by old wall street it's media and
whoever on twitter wants to come at me
like with some pseudo name or no name or
not yep because to me now
you're my marketing you are as long as i
can show your hate i retweet it all the
time yeah i can show the world how not
to be like you learn a lot by i've
always learned a lot like don't like you
learn a lot
from people on what to do
but you often learn a lot more on what
not to do so i think that
i think the ugliness of it
is an opportunity if you just
like that's how i deal with it i'm just
going to retweet it and let hedge nation
come after you because that's what
they're like you know they're not going
to let you get away with being a hater
of daniel dimartino booth i don't i mean
i don't i don't approach it the same way
but but occasionally somebody will say
oh you're just a chill for the fed and
i'm like that then i have to then i have
to retweet it out and go
clearly you don't have a google function
on your on your anything you have no
ability to google anything and then the
whole feed just goes
do you not know that she read a book
about how bad the fed is blah blah blah
blah blah
and that's when i'd like to make
examples of people is when they're
they're just they're not just being
hateful but they're ignorant and i'm
like
so um
four kids
yeah how old
uh
uh 14 jack will be 14 this week and then
you play hockey yeah they all do um
so
he's he's my first
he was born five days after i got fired
november 2nd of 2007 exactly so jax
jack's always been part of hedgehog he's
always been bopping around you know
so
he's uh
he's he's a beauty i love that kid i
love all my kids obviously but um cali's
11 years old she was my first daughter
she's playing hockey oh yeah she's the
ponytail power and uh very serious if
you were to hang out with cali she's
very she's like me um
and then lucy is my seven-year-old and
my six-year-old's name is rhys
so and all four of them play hockey yeah
yeah my wife loves that yeah she loves
driving
well we're all over the place all the
time but you know if maybe you can have
four in traveling teams and when they're
in high school yeah well they play all i
mean my wife played lacrosse uh in
college so they all and she runs
westport lacrosse in connecticut so
which cool you know so so they all play
lacrosse they all play hockey they
most of them play soccer all the girls
play soccer yeah you know i've got a
soccer player my one girl girl's a
soccer player it's it i love that sport
because i get to go on the sidelines and
there's no buffoons you know yelling
like hockey parents uh oh you'd be
surprised you haven't mentioned i go to
the far side games
dry texas soccer games boy can they get
crazy
really yeah i try i always take my dog
and i go to a far place on the side
where the players are like in the corner
i might look at a bit of a creep but uh
i just it's yeah it's good so um what
what advice would you give to young
parents because you've got you've got a
broad spectrum of ages what what what
what's what's the what's the best thing
because you obviously come from a
tight-knit family so what's what what's
your biggest takeaway as what's what's
most important for you to accomplish as
a parent
no snowflakes like we don't um i do not
that's part of the current culture that
i don't
i don't agree with at all
i think you know construction cancel
culture blah blah blah yeah and raising
our kids with constructive criticism is
like a big deal to us not letting
this you know again oh you did such a
great job and even if they didn't
you know um so participation trophies
yeah we i mean i i'm big on
like parenting and coaching i coach i've
spent a lot of time coaching too when it
comes to mentoring kids i think the most
important thing is their work ethic
and and and being able to handle um
some you know level of criticism i call
i call it i have an acronym it's like
kind of like the quads but it's your
ticker okay so it's like you you have to
have talent you have to be intelligent
you have to have a compete level but you
have to be resilient because
whenever these two things are in
question that resilience is what is
really going to make the difference yeah
you know if danielle's getting chirped
at on twitter
she's one hell of a resilient texan you
know somebody helped you with that
that's good you're not a snowflake right
so
that with my kids that's a big that's a
big deal uh whether i'm coaching them or
they're my own kids well if they take
that away with them then they'll be
independent which 25 of american adults
are not because they're living with
their parents yeah i mean the the issue
i mean
the average american reads seven minutes
a day i mean to think about like all the
issues that we can
like all that's the other thing like
make sure your kids are constantly
reading books instead of these damn
screens i mean there's
there's a lot that we can help them with
well i have one final burning question
because i've i've learned a lot about
hockey
with kids at culver and from you
what's your team
what my nhl team
this is kind of embarrassing the toronto
maple leafs
we're talking like long term cycle
long bear market
who's who's in the winning quad this
this this year
in the nhl i don't know and new york
rangers look pretty good i don't think
they're going to win the cuff i mean
well well
i i i need more information
my my bayesian inference processes i
need more data it's too early it's too
early in the hockey season yeah man it's
the risk the only thing that i know that
there's still very high probability of
happening is that the toronto maple
leafs still don't win a stanley cup
well it's okay i mean you could be a
university of texas longhorn football
fan as well
is that bad well we're we're in several
rebuilding decades several decades well
you do have matthew mcconaughey yeah all
right all right all right yes we do
um keith this has been a blast
it really has and we i think we only had
like three or four so we did really good
on on the obscenities part you know this
is still going to be at least pg-13 but
seriously thank you for coming into new
york thank you for being part of the
reopening of the economy and thank you
for taking this time today
i've learned so much and i know the
viewers will as well so thank you thank
you for having me it was awesome
thanks
[Music]